Lithuania was the first country to leave
the USSR when it declared its
independence in March of 1990 beginning
a 2-year process which culminated in the
death of the Soviet Union but given that
the USSR didn't want Lithuania to leave
and was more than capable of using Force
to keep it in the Union why was
Lithuania allowed to go and why was
their minimal intervention from Moscow
so as of the late 1980s the USSR wasn't
doing so well the economy had been
stagnant for well over a decade the
people living there no longer trusted
the government to act in their interest
and it was clear from the collapse of
the wara pact that the USSR was on the
decline many national groups demanded
greater autonomy from Moscow and in
lithuania's case it was granted it as
the media opened up talk of Independence
grew and when gorbachov didn't shoot
them for simply thinking about it the
lithuanians realized that leaving was
now a real possibility and in February
1990 when Lithuania held its first free
election since being annexed its people
overwhelmingly chose non-communist
candidates who wanted out a month later
the new Lithuanian parliament passed the
act on the restoration of the state of
Lithuania at which point the world held
its breath to see if the USSR would send
troops to crush the movement so how did
Moscow react well obviously the news of
lithuania's Declaration of Independence
was worrying and gorbachov's government
waited a month before doing anything
their First Act was to demand that
Lithuania undec its independence and
apologize but to the surprise of exactly
zero people they didn't do this as such
gorbachov opted to sanction Lithuania
and block the import of goods this was
incredibly damaging to the Lithuanian
economy and the living standards of the
people there after couple of months the
government in vilus caved and agreed to
put Independence on hold and negotiate
in exchange for the sanctions being
lifted by early 1991 the economy in
Lithuania was still in trouble and
protests broke out against the new
government to gorbachov it looked like
the tide was turning and so he sent
troops into Lithuania to nominally
protect the Russians speaking people
there from a decaying government They
seized important buildings and shot
protesters but still the lithuanians
wouldn't budge and they demanded
Independence the Western world was
concerned about what to do because its
leaders saw gorbachov as a reasonable
man that they could work with but also
importantly they wanted to see communism
rolled back the United States pressured
its allies not to recognize Lithuania so
positive relations with the USSR could
be preserved and this worked well mostly
Iceland and soon afterwards Denmark
recognized lithuania's sovereignty which
to many living there meant that more
recognition was inevitably coming Moscow
was at this point kind of busy trying to
keep the rest of the country together
and occupying Lithuania was only going
to make things worse when gorbachov was
almost overthrown in August of 1991
there were worries that he would use
force in Lithuania to reassert his
authority of course the country was
decaying too rapidly for this to happen
and in early September the Soviet
government recognized lithuania's
Independence and the rest of the world
soon followed I hope you enjoyed this
episode with a special thanks to my
patrons James Bizet Kelly Money Maker
Sky Chappelle kitka Andy McGee Anthony
Becket Alex Schwin rod D Martin Udan
Wang AF Firefly Spencer lighfoot Marcus
arner Y and hockey Captain side dog
Marvin CAU kimun Yun the mcer Gustav
Swan Maggie Paskowski calling Dr Howard
Dr Fine Dr Howard spinning three plates
copper tone shenin words about books
podcast Ked Alder Wood Winston kwood Jim
Stromberg Charles I and Miss is it